we had a parent thing with a school
psychologist like a person and she was
saying she was talking she says and your
children are gonna be complicated people
and by the way just for all of you to
know sometimes you do give birth to an
unlikable child it happened the cyllage
appointment she goes it happens and if
you're feeling guilty for not liking
your own child believe me that is a part
of reality that is that is that exists
yes that person yeah we're all like hey
you know I've decided because I take
Tiger this kid nazy in place this kid
bill place all the time they're just
cool dad they're you know it's like the
cool dad yeah we hit it off right away
cuz I go cute kid male experience no the
pack ha ha and it's true like he's not
that's what everyone says like oh my god
cute kid and you know all the kids
around go dude you a cute kid man he's
gonna be big in his alright I just look
at although the kids he's alright I did
he was he blends in I did his job out of
a lineup be tough for me to pick alright
a joke I did joke in my stand-up I went
my kids are so cute to me that literally
if they were just a little cuter I might
eat them like I might blame I I'm sorry
we'll go from her now yes first like I
need a muzzle sometimes I want to bite
my son's face I saw him in a group of 30
kids again I was like yeah I mean it's
just being honest I'm like that kid
scooter that gets cuter it's you know
did he go through and pick them stand up
there's always one guy or one gal who's
[ __ ] dying yeah my buddy my buddy
Sean is such a good guy he's in the
front row at the improv look I do you
know I make people laugh but he started
laughing the minute like joke one soon
like his face was so red he's super
blond you have yet this one yeah I've
had it may have been Australia I forget
where I was that but the kind of front
row you know nice guy but when I yeah he
wants to be I told him it bro
I appreciate you loving the show you
gotta just kind of just chill for a sec
it though man did I pin on the winter
again that's what's up that's what's oh
no did I tell you I'm in the one out
that's it slow
clap oh no god bless you sir did I tell
make me feel like Kevin Hart right well
when I was in wiseguys I don't know if I
tell you this in Utah the Samoan fighter
I had a Samoan fighter in my okay well
he's Samoan and he had two other buddies
and they looked kind of tough young guys
good guys but he decided to start going
okay I was a war cry and I go I weep
from because some are you know and I was
like oh boy and he was so thick and he
was and I was trying to incorporate it
and then I finally I'd say yet to stop
talking to your friend you have to stop
talking now I got to be a bad guy honey
I want you here you're a young man I
love this but I got to kick you out cuz
you're because what happened was and you
just got big strong people but they're
all kind of looking at him and nobody's
gonna say [ __ ] to him he just keeps a
big and I was he just looked too tough
he just said like a bowling ball a
[ __ ] bowling ball and turns out he
was a pro fighter you know we said no he
told me he's got this he's got his next
profile when we took pictures but he
just every time I would do is what world
is that okay it was a problem we did
where were you born worried that's
acceptable
young man oh man no I was young happy he
wanted one direction he just want to be
heard yeah he was a you yell out at a
comic show like that that's insane enjoy
the belt while you can to stay and say
your farewell before your next fight
just dark [ __ ] right I can new God dog I
have to retweet that myself which is
some weird I mean it's just some dark I
mean it's just like each is a scary
individual but he's not you can tell
he's nice met the guys nice scary [ __ ]
what else yet you said when you met he
wasn't as big as you thought right I
didn't think he as big as I thought but
then again he's in clothes I never think
anyone's that big I'm an opposite of
Brian
I never thinks that they even went that
jacked some football players will
surprise me but no I did not think he's
that big but then when I saw next over
in like the case [ __ ] huge
Rodion said hey do you think France is
that big egos bigger bigger than I
thought
even next over him he's bigger than I
thought so
I'll take everyone's work for it he's
enormous when I saw him we fought over a
hot dog
I see gave it out to him I had wanted no
part of that again I was in goddamn
gucci boots and tight jeans he's Francis
in Ghana so I did not want any I
relinquished that hot dog would your
game plan be against such a ferocious
opponent like Francis and chin I believe
you're a great producer of the show but
we need more background on you and what
you do outside of the show
chin needs his own segment on the show
no thank you
you mean like chinder yeah we saw that
went and out but that's [ __ ] finish
because solver adores boob went I want I
like her boob there I want I want that
boob all right well that's strange I'm
down for a segment for chin or MJ if you
guys think of something but have to be
consistent my fun one its art they just
happen organically can't really write
those but the first part of the question
what would your game plan be against
such a fresh run run I would never be in
there however if for some weird reason I
had to fight the guy it would be I'm
either so far out or I'm so far in how
about never in that middle area where he
can land one of those bombs from
Cameroon so my my whole theme for that
camp would be like let's try to get this
dude to break let's see if we can break
him just to pure pressure
tenacity and will and my forehead is can
be in his chest I'm never giving them a
break i Mike are your cardio I'm sure
Steve is gonna fall this game plan your
cardio better be second to none that
night because I'm willing to go five
rounds and walk through hell to beat
this guy and it's not gonna be a short
night for him I'm gonna make it a living
hell I'm never let him get off I'm
always rushing to him I'm always rushing
rushing rushing closing the distance my
heads can be in his chin under hooks if
it's boring I don't give a flying [ __ ]
I'm doing what I can do to drag the sky
to the later rounds let's see if we can
swim let's see if France can swim that'd
be the only game plan that's literally
the only way to beat him
or bring out the bow booster or put a
bow bow straw up your [ __ ] so you
don't have to fight it or if I'm Purdue
my jump down you're just a [ __ ] guy
you can't open up when I don't tuck in
the Bruce Springsteen of stand-up comic
I don't give out your Bruce Springsteen
music video watch that and tell me him
and Bryan Callen aren't [ __ ] the same
kind of entertain a channeling Brian
listen so he can't go up and his Steve
Burns tour and like God never opened
offered to open up the shell never would
say that you [ __ ] killed my morning
my favorite Sam tripoli jokes is I got
to keep doing this so karate starts
paying the bills but anyway whenever I'm
like I [ __ ] hate this guy yeah you
guys know yeah I know you know I didn't
join us right now but I'm only doing
this until Chrysler's pay the bill so
[ __ ] you got it privates off dog God
kills me that's one joke of 50,000 gonna
throw those out the time I started
coming man I started yeah I know else I
started Tom Segura I know I was in a
[ __ ] euro cheaper Groundlings class when
I'm like there comes this moment dude
like I'm a competitive [ __ ] when
it comes to comedy and it's like you can
either have that moment you're like oh
dude we got another gunslinger here or
you can be like I like this guy won't be
friends with him right and Tom Segura
was so [ __ ] fast I'm like I get
either [ __ ] be like a [ __ ] rival
or I could be like love this guy so I'm
like dude you're tall you're successful
you can stand up yeah he goes I never
try to go come with me I'll show you how
to do it and for a week I took that dude
around for [ __ ] showing and how long
ago was this amazing sad like I wanted
11 years ago I guess in the world and
he's amazed you remember when I used to
call you the monsters you know wide
remember what when I started doing that
well I would always have to [ __ ]
follow you right I did an hour of I
[ __ ] and at The Comedy Store in La
Jolla
I threw flames I [ __ ] literally got
off the stage and I went there's no way
anybody on the planet I was being
serious and then Brides on Bryan's not
Brian everybody loses my show and I I
don't know if he gets mammy by Mike like
this last show
like the greatest murderer I've ever put
together it was such a fun show and I'm
like there's only one dude that could
close that out who does not care and
it's like him he's like I gotta get up I
gotta get to this other [ __ ] place
I'm like okay just go up do like do like
10 15 and get out 40 minutes later he's
like and that why he's blocking it
people are loving them and it's just
like I hope you make your spot but
you're the only one that could close it
you're the only one I love doing it but
I thought the comic store I threw flames
and I was just like I never forgot I did
it a full hour and five minutes and I go
there's just Sam's gotta follow me I
love him and I know you're tough but I
go there's no one who can follow that no
it was just because sometimes in a room
when you take that much oxygen out of a
room they're all gone this [ __ ] guy
gets up not even missing a beat and I'm
not I've counted the minutes I'll never
forget it because I couldn't stop
watching for 55 minutes
he had them laughing he had them
laughing as hard or harder you just you
just destroyed I was like bin sessional
oh professional